hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mod
vorstellung von der kopie in pace
modifikation bzw der geocache bot diese
mod fügt diese drei teams hin zu dir
hier schon eingeblendet sehen wir können
auch jemanden seite nach rechts gehen
diesmal die medium die latte eustacchio
dead block und de oder dick und der
georgische leiser um die kisten
beschäftigen wir uns gleich erstmal
beziehungen vertiefen
ebenfalls ist das crafting rezept
einfach unten in der beschreibung
verlinkt also dass die website verlinkt
viele meinen immer in den kommentaren
beschäftigt sich immer so lang mit
diesen kräften rezepten um die zu zeigen
du kannst uns einfach den link geben und
wenn man sich die mal drunter lädt
interessierte noch das spart dabei ihre
juni erst mal zu erfahren was diesem ort
überhaupt alles hinzufügt erst mal tritt
jetzt in unser ganz normale welt überall
dieses geo.de tor auf und das können wir
ganz normal abbauen und dann bekommen
wir diese g oder blöcke hier die sind so
ein bisschen ihr seht schon das alles
recht pink pink ist einfach die farbe
von einem ort die es noch nicht gibt
noch rätsel ist ein bisschen rot
allerdings bekommt man all diese sachen
und mit diesen sachen kann man sich dann
beispielsweise mit dem stick und dieser
sache kann man sich diesen geo
visualizer machen dann kann man sich
beispielsweise auch mit ein paar anderen
crafting rezepten diese box machen diese
tiny dann diese small medium large und
youtube diese boxen haben verschiedene
sachen die die können in diesem geo
visualizer komme ich gleich am ende
einfach mal ganz kurz um zwar erst mal
ganz kurz was diese mod überhaupt
grundsätzlich macht und zwar könnt ihr
hier mit eure häuser oder schlafzimmer
eure räume eure welt mehr oder weniger
anteil eines bios alles mit kopieren und
in eine kiste packen und zwar neben mir
dafür ist beispielsweise einfach mal die
dateien ig jazz einzige was diese jets
quasi unterscheidet ist das crafting
einerseits und die größe der blöcke die
da reinpassen
zwar ist das crafting nicht bei allen
relativ ähnlich allerdings braucht man
beispielsweise wenn ich mir eine utah
jazz machen möchte muss ich mir erst
eine lounge machen davor eine medium
davor eines motto davor eine teil also
das ist quasi den ablauf mehr oder
weniger ich mache das ganze jetzt
erstmal hier ganz kurz an dem simplen
beispiel und zwar hole ich mir jetzt
hier erst mal ganz viele von diesen g
oder blöcken und setzte die jetzt hier
zu so einem drei mal drei kasten ich
glaube ich lass dir sogar einfach mal so
mit den blättern damit ihr genau so
etwas überhaupt meinen und zwar ist das
jetzt ein drei mal drei kasten da setzt
jetzt die teilnehmer ein idiot es hier
vor wenn ich die hier versetzen würde
wird dieser bereiche gescannt werden
dann wäre das hier nicht mehr mit drauf
allerdings setzen die geo testen und ihr
seht schon die bleibt immer im inventar
erst mal dass es gleich im creative denn
sonst würde jetzt halt weg im survival
dann kann ich einfach mal rechts drauf
machen und dann seht ihr schon okay okay
krass was sich jedoch jetzt
jetzt gehe ich einfach mal hin und gebe
jetzt zum beispiel zuerst mal ein link
jetzt blicke ich mal hier ok auf die
kiste drauf nicht sehe ich schon okay
hier ist alles weg und wenn ich jetzt
hier mit links liegt draufschreiben
creative auch bekomme ich eine neue
kiste jetzt habe ich eine zweite teil
nigerias da steht in klammern hinter
pink hier nochmal unten darauf acht
damit das eigene täter steht jetzt pink
und jetzt kann ich beispielsweise daher
gehen und sagen okay blablabla ich bin
wieder zu hause hier soviel g oder
häufig gefunden mache rechts drauf und
klicke einfach hier und das ganze stellt
sich wieder hin und ich kann meine g
oder chats hier einmal wieder mitnehmen
dann ist das hier drin okay das ist
jetzt hier nicht mehr drin weil ich in
rente bin und alles möglich ein bisschen
kompliziert ist auch egal jedenfalls
kann ich ihnen ganz simpel einfach
sachen kopiert die ganzen kisten
entscheiden sich dann dementsprechend
einfach wie viele blöcke da reinpassen
wenn ich beispielsweise hier die small
hier seht ihr hier sind schon fünf
blöcke mit am start hier in der medien
sind bis zu sieben mal sieben am start
hier sind neun mal neun in der lounge
und in der kutsche sind elf mal elf
kisten kann man auch extrem gut zum
mining benutzen das heißt ich kann jetzt
beispielsweise mal daher gehen und sagen
okay kommen dieser berg da möchte ich
eigentlich einen coolen tunnel
reinmachen dann gehe ich hier einfach
mal hin packe hier sondern eben am
besten irgendwo eine mitte wenn ich hier
den tunnel rein machen möchte heute da
vorne wieder so einem chip
ich mache jetzt einfach mal so eine
kiste
zack clique drauf und wenn das ganze mal
tunnel 1 beispielsweise dann mache ich
jetzt kann ich das hier mitnehmen und
jetzt haben wir hier einen kleinen
bereits kann ich hier vorne wieder
hängen kann er wieder eine kiste
hinstellen kann jeder hier drücken gebe
ich hier tunnel 2 1 so hab ich nämlich
auch wieder drin
und jetzt natürlich ein bisschen blöd
mit dem wasser also das ding nimmt auch
wasser mit allerdings nur bis hier kann
er nicht über diese grenze hinaus gehen
deswegen stimmt dass sie ganz so ein
bisschen runter und jetzt habe ich auf
jeden fall schon mal heftig fiel
weggefahren werden sehen wir irgendein
recht ob das ist eisen wenn wir uns
jetzt denken
der tunnel sei ein bisschen scheiße aus
wir machen mal dass der noch
beschissener aussehen weil schöner kann
man den ärger machen dann nehme ich
jetzt einfach mal hier beispielsweise
tunnel zwei drücke draufdrücken hier und
da kann ich das ganze hier wieder
hinsetzen es sieht jetzt extrem scheiße
aus das muss ich wirklich sagen es sieht
sogar einen kleinen wasserfall gerade
kriechen es bedenken ich habe gerade das
was vorher hier war das hier stand
vorher quasi gespiegelt hierhin
das habe ich einfach umgedreht habe es
hier hingesetzt und jetzt habe ich das
ganze hier am start ist wegen ist jetzt
noch so eine harte kante allerdings kann
man die mod natürlich auch für was
sinnvolles benutzen nicht nur für so ein
schwachsinn ich mir nämlich einfach mal
hier so einen kleinen enchantment raum
kräfte und zwar setze ich jetzt einfach
alles voll mit bücherregal
ich müsste schon hinkommen mit der
passenden länger ich habe jetzt mal eben
schnell das ganze aufgebaut und zwar
sind vielleicht ein bisschen viele
bücherregal aber einfach nur so zur
demonstration und zwar das ganze fünf
hoch und 15 die länge und auch hier fünf
in die breite das heißt 5 x 5 man müsste
das ganze dann abziehen und jetzt haben
wir quasi drin so eine kleine kiste wir
haben hier ein crafting table einen ofen
und wir haben hier einen chapman table
wo ich jetzt sachen einfach einlegen
kann wieder habe ich dann ein inventar
naja egal jedenfalls kann ich jetzt
sachen rein legen und die dann einfach
kräften oder irgendwie verzaubern und
die habe ich noch ein kleines päckchen
wo ich mich reinlegen kann
und da denke ich mir natürlich okay im
survival mode ich gehe jetzt auf einer
höhlentour und möchte jetzt in der höhle
aber ich möchte jetzt nicht meine ganze
taschen immer aus lernen und auch nicht
ein crafting table mitnehmen und alles
mögliche
dann können wir hier einfach noch mal
gucken okay was macht denn die medien
jazz die machten mich 7 und diesmal die
macht fünf das heißt rein theoretisch
das sieht immer so hoch aus tieren rein
theoretisch würde die small caps das
alles packen und wir sehen sie hat es
gepackt krieg mir mit links liegt drauf
bekommen wir die sache habe ich mich
vorhin verdrückt das noch ein
bücherregal aber egal jedenfalls nehme
das jetzt mit gehen beispielsweise in
der höhle des eine super höhle jetzt war
mir in der höhle der name ist ok kommen
[ __ ] ich bin hier gerade total von
monstern verfolgt hier nach dem motto
ich mal eben hier so zac und bitte
hinsetzen und jetzt ist das ganze ein
bisschen komisch weil das jetzt in der
wandel ist aber das wird dann quasi
ersetzt das ganze hier wird dadurch
ersetzt was ich habe vorhin quasi
kopiert habe und jetzt habe ich das
ganze hier wieder am start und das ist
eigentlich extrem cooles ganze
funktioniert mit allen blöcken aus es
funktioniert sogar mit wasser und mit
lava also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
mal hier einen lover einmal nehmen und
hier einfach mal den hier rein zäune in
seine drei mal drei scheiße und hier
ihren dateien die chefs nehme kann ich
einfach mal so drauf klicken dann habe
ich ihr lover drinnen kann die mitnehmen
und dann nehme ich mir die einfach mal
unten ins inventar und kann jetzt hier
beispielsweise unten in den see einfach
mal ohne wasser hier die kiste aufmachen
und dann seht ihr schon da war die
larven wurde zu ob sie die hand das
natürlich sehr sehr gut funktioniert mit
allen sachen außer mit mops und entities
also entities sind ja so was wie eine
rüstung
da oder wie ein kart das habt ihr mir
immer beigebracht in den micro effekt
folgen wo ich feststellte man alles
sorry das ist hier noch ein bisschen
ruckeln ich bin jetzt am wochenende wo
ihr das video gerade sehe dass ihr seht
das video wahrscheinlich gerade sogar am
samstag ich bin samstag sonntag montag
dienstag unterwegs auf achse ein paar
sachen mehr oder weniger nicht für
youtube plan aber ein bisschen studium
und was weiß ich alles
jedenfalls war das jetzt erstmal für die
motte hat war es das jetzt erstmal für
die mod vorstellung ich hoffe die
nächsten tage kommen regelmäßig videos
also ich hoffe ich habe das geschafft
das alles vor zu produzieren auch mit
den effekten dienstag und alles mögliche
und dann wird sich zeigen wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr sehr
dollar beide bewertungen freuen wenn ihr
weitere max kennen die ich vorstellen
soll ab und in die beschreibung der wird
mir auch in die kommentare geschrieben
und dann sehen uns im nächsten video
wieder typ bin ein sehr sehr kluger
mensch ich habe einfach vergessen euch
diesen geo visualizer irgendwie zu
zeigen das heißt ich werde jetzt einfach
mal euch doch mal ganz schnell zeigen
was dieser geophysiker ja ja ja
überhaupt mal und zwar wenn ich hier
eine medium getestet und ich setze jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal hin und ich
nehme diesen gegner dann kann ich
einfach rechts ich darauf machen und ich
sehe den bereich der von dieser medien
jazz dann quasi mehr oder weniger
erfasst wird das ist ganz gut wenn man
gucken möchte okay was nimmt diese tests
überhaupt alles mit das heißt man kann
ja nochmal proportion ihren wenn man
seine elf mal elf kister hat kann man
natürlich nicht direkt auf den ersten
blick sehen
ok welche elf blöcke werden davon die
zum abt eingeschlossen denn ich kann er
zielgenau sehen okay das geht hier genau
bis hierhin hier vorne geht es hier um
die kurve wenn ich denke mein okay das
passt doch nicht so richtig dann gehe
ich lieber noch mal hierhin kira mit den
geo visualizer gehe ich hier hin und
dann sage ich mir okay
hier fehlt mir noch ein kleiner bereich
das heißt ich nehme dann noch eine time
jazz und guckt jedoch mal ob das dann so
passt und dann sieht man dass das ganze
sich mehr oder weniger ergänzt und dann
passt das alles und das war jetzt
wirklich vom video und wir sehen uns
ihnen mal anders wieder typisch